[MUSIC]
I chose librarianship because I like
being introduced to new ideas, and new
knowledge on a constant basis, and I
found that I also like learning new
technology and I found librarianship to
be sort of a good fit for this.
I'm very interested in library automation...
A general interest in technology.
And as I was studying library science,
I was gravitating towards the areas of
working with automated processing of data
and software solutions to library problems.
I was very interested in the field of
medical informatics and the role that
librarians could possibly play, and I
couldn't have found a more exciting place.
The role of the library is changing. So
again, I think it's a very exciting time
to be in libraries, because we don't have...
We have the traditional role, but it's
expanded so much, because with the Internet
and all of that, we have so many other
services that the library provides.
Libraries offer me the opportunity to
provide services to people, and also
I'm always interested in
computer technologies.
My job combines services and
computer technology.
I've been both in academia and private
sector before, and then with this...
with NLM, I think when it's anything
to do with biomedical information,
this is the place to be with its...you know,
a hundred and seventy-five year tradition of
making biomedical information accessible.
It's great to work at NLM. I think I will
retire from here.